[Music]
input baby news submitted by Meghan
Montgomery well oh [ __ ] is that
Montgomery just her name that's the old
ass name you [ __ ] dick sounds like a
furniture store whole a family claims
they had to put their dog down after a
FedEx driver crushed him with the thrown
package oh I would scorch the [ __ ]
earth to crush a dog with a package it
could be a smart dog in a big package
yeah this guy's strong he threw
something that was heavy enough to
crushes well-baby dog and it was just
like a [ __ ] whatever you threw
shouldn't probably not have been thrown
they ordered a mini fridge what about
the dog actually paying attention to
what the [ __ ] the would be really good
at dodging things this will just like
[Laughter]
when they see things in people yeah I
tried putting like a bag of dog food on
top of my dog to see what happened if I
if he carried his own food makes sense
if I drop it and then the minute I let
go he runs away like a responsible dog
dogs are good at dodging would imagine
it just like a surprise of that not even
after I go back to this FedEx that my
should be in the NFL because he threw it
so hard yeah so this this is a four
pound Yorkie Oh like anything can crush
this cat or dog [ __ ] this is a doll but
every Korean girl has and it's a name
Coco or baby or Chanel
so they actually live in Venice the
beach here in California it looks like
eight year olds oh the hair is so
[ __ ] shiny what do how do I get my
hair like that
oh so Bacchus baby all right
so what happened was uh you know how
like in Venice Beach they all the
properties have like fences you can't
even see the balloons because they're
all lit up cuz when you're there at
night you find out why right so a lot of
crack addicts yeah so then they're like
this FedEx worker just chopped a package
over that fence cuz they had like it's
pretty high up
oh no instead of just opening the door I
don't know the procedure that they
usually do but he wasn't supposed to be
throwing
[ __ ] package over the gate and and so
that's when it landed on Cooper hello or
pound your key close enough to Coco
mm-hmm it's like a white version Coco
poor Cooper like immediately when you
toss the the package that's one of the
owners yeah like they heard and so they
ran over and they saw the dog and so
they had the immediately picked up the
box and Cooper was in a puddle of blood
oh yeah that means the bones broke is it
wrong what did they would they order you
get microwave that's what I was thinking
something heavy I think it's one of
those build your own coffee tables Oh
[ __ ] 25 pounds like a dumbbell or
some salt they said that that um the dog
suffered serious lung and liver injuries
they smashed the baby
what if they ordered a statue of the dog
and it's exactly the size of the dog
marble statue and it perfectly on the
dot and they're perfectly questioned it
would have just moved over like an inch
it would have missed it because it's
perfectly the dog size but it was like
perfect like the circle peasants were
shaped perfectly like the dog as well he
actually paid extra to get the box
shaped like a cartoon it's like when
they got crushed a dog disappeared on
the bottom nobody see it yet they took
the dead dog to go get x-rayed no they
were dying they had to put him down
insurance purposes and it looks like
he's saying can you believe this [ __ ] no
it's pretty about that all [ __ ] fans
thanks guys
I mean it's gonna break the [ __ ]
sucks cuz he probably meant well he
meant like he met lazy is what
[ __ ] you then jacket well I mean I
wouldn't throw anything that higher
because it's gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ] inside
than throwing a German Shepherd over I
guess cuz you've done that I don't
imagine you order a dog online and then
they ship your German Shepherd off and
eat them so to get rid of that you have
to throw a bigger dog [ __ ] great dane
or something God that sucks you like the
headline said they had to they ended up
choosing to euthanize the dog because it
was in so much pain I know so they're
suing right dude I would [ __ ] sue
sore I broke my back at this point -
everyone's getting everyone good yeah I
should hit me - saw the dog you slip on
something and then you cracked your back
you show up with two x-rays is the dog
that train is mine I laid down next to
the dog put the package up me and then I
scream immediately yeah so they don't
mention anything about them suing but I
imagine they will yeah dude yeah so then
fed I feel like cats when I got out the
way [ __ ] no the cancer was like the the
wife she ended up saying like okay well
first of all FedEx said we take this
matter very seriously and we were
working directly with those involved to
determine the circumstances behind this
event based on the outcome of our
investigation we will take the
appropriate action so they say that the
response is not satisfactory and there
you are again she said I feel they need
to say they're going to institute a
corporate-wide mandate that drivers
cannot throw packages that's what I want
to hear I don't want to hear it will
look into it our grandchild plays up out
here my mother is out of here gardening
I'm outdoor gardening she's like the
package was so heavy it should it has
struck one of us it would have caused
damage very very severe damage so is it
illegal to call your employee a stupid
[ __ ] oh no if they said sorry our
drivers are stupid [ __ ] Reuven nice I
can't believe this happened
they're not even supposed to be throwing
packages
furthermore no drivers shall chuck toss
volley and if they do they'll get fired
immediately yeah why can't the hope you
[ __ ] roll like dude it is I mean I'm
sure it's part of training you don't get
drove a [ __ ]
well I've literally seen them throw my
[ __ ] over the gate and you can't open
the gate and like at one time I ordered
like a gallant what no I'm just thinking
cuz like I feel like it would be a
pleasant surprise like you're just
chilling max despise all feeling oh [ __ ]
but then I'm thinking about it well [ __ ]
if it happens every day you'll probably
get pretty annoying it's broken cuz my
broken shoe and I'm like you're in your
[ __ ] lounge chair and then the
[ __ ] package left for the for the
FedEx drivers who toss it right all of
them and it's [ __ ] up cuz there's want
to do it right and the ones that do it
wrong exactly these guys are like like
merit like Olympic sprinters they'll
[ __ ] ring your doorbell
you like yous know how my home oh
there's there's two steps of stairs
going up to my house he'll ring the
doorbell
I'm literally next to a door opening
he's already halfway down the street
yeah bolted out of there yeah like they
don't make it like they think they want
stick a little sticker on they just ring
and I open the door immediately sticker
on this fine here's her package think
you want to keep coming back you want to
keep climbing up these bear dance and
when you get polish mates do guys come
to you like the visitors and [ __ ] like
weeds in their hair you're you're real
you're a crime somebody stairs I went to
summary doorways
oh I feel terrible when I open up my
post mates and it's like an 80 year old
woman who's climbing
two sets of stairs I was just like you
have fat but yeah I took fat for that it
happened a couple weeks feels like oh my
god I'm so sorry she needed the exercise
oh yeah you hoped her I feel bad when
the parents send their kids you ever get
like Yugi open the door and it's like a
five-year-old why do you feel that this
is your job
youthful why not why you put it white
man did you look no much energy time
waiting in the car as if the kids not
doing the job right but I'm like the
kids doing our job it's [ __ ]
dangerous out there with the shoe yeah
it's all gone it's a good point open the
door dude the funniest delivery woman I
had was great I have a video of it on my
ring doorbell do I open the door so do
you know girls like wear those onesies
like the the one-piece onesies and and
you and it's about a rock yeah the
bodysuit snaps on the crotch yeah and
then then be covered by the pants right
this chick
did not snap it on the bottom so it was
just like it looked like a phone that
was going up it's bright yellow and
you're gonna know exactly what kind of
person this is I open doors Jonathan
Liberty taking this all in like this was
the most crack headed looking I think
that's the guy version of when he shows
up with the loose next time it's
supposed to be tight but you're like you
recorded that [ __ ] like what I opened
the door I was like you gotta be [ __ ]
[ __ ] me like she fell three words
into one jaw literally did she try to
bum a cigarette off you chewing gum the
whole time like he didn't give a [ __ ]
she like super tight jeans on I'm pretty
sure chef Cortes is off but it often is
the best part oh it is
yeah man I [ __ ] hate when they throw
my packages and this [ __ ] sucks an
entire family member
yeah I do this well they gotta settle
you ever try to block oh yeah let you
see the package going over no my house
no no no when the goddamn gate it goes
right back and falls on the FedEx guy's
head killed you then you just tried the
package that you ordered at least you
saved the dog sounds really good so once
again in this article they didn't say
what the guy ordered did they well our
media is terrible
cuz it's important they never asked a
real question most worried what if I was
a 1 pound object I will tell you what
happened here they did mention it in the
video like the news report video but it
was like I think it was like crystal or
something that's why I'm all my work
crystal Swann just [ __ ] yeah it was a
crystal ball that's a crystal dog statue
like okay I was not a hundred percent
sure I see through dog crystals are
[ __ ] hands why I have to to find out
okay so if if the dog's bones broke
broke did the package at least not break
they did not mention oh god I wouldn't
even want that filthy black me right
there man I have blood on my package
don't want this every time you pass by
that crystal dog you remind yourself of
the tragic use it for the grave but if I
was cheap I'd be like I paid for [ __ ]
[Music]